the next talk is on the randomizing the
isolation lemma by rote is good I would
like to thank the organizers for
inviting me for giving this talk so this
talk is on Durand maizing the famous
isolation lemma of move Emilio veggie
language Maharani and will give an a
geometric approach towards the
randomization of isolation lemma and
will show for two settings this approach
works so this is based on two joints
work with the container and Thomas zero
so let's start with the isolation lemma
so for any weight function defined on a
sixth lecture E is the easier set and we
have an integer weight function so
weight of any subset of e is just taken
to be the sum of the elements in that
set sum of the weights of the element
indexes and now what the isolation lemma
says is that suppose you are given any
family of subsets from this set E and
now you assign weights randomly so each
element is given away to randomly from
say this range from 1 to twice the size
of the fit then with a probability at
least half there will be a unique
minimum weight set in your family B and
and this is a bit surprising when you
see it for the first time and you might
expect that the different the number of
sets in all weight classes will be
uniformly distributed but they say that
when we look at the minimum weight or
the maximum weight with high probability
there will be only a unique set and
another important thing is that it works
for any family so here there is no
assumption on this family it is an
arbitrary family of sausage and so this
lemma was given in the context of
perfect matchings so they using this
lemma they give a randomized square
algorithm for the perfect matching
problem and later it was also applied to
give a randomized algorithm for the
linear Metro intersection from them and
then since there are many other
applications in complexity theory so you
can solve polynomial I mean you can give
a randomized randomized polynomial time
test for the polynomial idea testing
problem which Michael introduced and so
the this reduction from so brilliant was
Ronnie gave a reduction from stag to
unambiguous set which is a randomized
reduction and so Mulla Mulla was Ronnie
Ronnie given alternate proof using the
same I solution lemma so they reduce
from click to unique link so I mean this
reduction shows that even if you assume
that you're np-hard problem has at most
one satisfying assignment even then it's
hard to solve and Reinhardt and a lender
showed that this class NL non
deterministic log space and class you
will an NB both non deterministic logs
things as they are sort of equals with
polynomial advice and there is another
problem called disjoint path so given a
graph you are given two sources and two
sinks s 1 and s 2 and T 1 T 2 and you
want to find out whether there is a path
from s 1 to T 1 and s 2 2 T 2 which are
disjoint so this problem has randomized
polynomial time algorithm again you
choose is the isolation lemma so in all
these settings the only randomized thing
used is this coming up with such a wait
assignment which implies a unique
minimum weight set in appropriate family
so the family of search here is are all
different corresponding to the fitting
so if you can D randomized this lemma
meaning if you can construct such a
weight assignment deterministically then
here you will get deterministic results
so for example you will get perfect
matching a linear Metroid intersection
in NC and you will solve polynomial I
need testing if you they randomized it
for appropriate family of say
and you will get a deterministic
reduction here and you will show NL
equal to UL and you'll solve this
disjoint path problem in determine
suppose Omega uses actually means by
divine demising this lemma yeah so I
mean I'll go to in the next place yeah
so roughly it means you want to
construct such a weight assignment
deterministically but yeah there are
many conditions on this so first of all
I mean so here we see the weights were
polynomially bounded in the random
vector segment so we want that property
that when we construct this weight
assignment deterministically the which
should be polynomially bounded and I
mean now first thing you can see is you
can't do it for all families of subsets
because if you give me any weight
assignment with polynomially bounded
weights there will be two sets which are
equal to it because there are
exponential mean set so you can give
this as your family and then the weight
function will not isolate in this family
so what we want is I mean you can relax
this you can say that you are allowed to
give a polynomial a large list of weight
assignments not just one way to find and
now you want to guarantee that for any
family at least one of the weight
assignments should be isolating but even
this is impossible you can't do it for
all families because I mean you can show
using the arguments involving polynomial
interesting that this is impossible I
don't know of any direct cont counting
argument so what you can hope to do is
can hope to do it for families which
have succinct representation so what is
the current representation I mean it can
be for example it can be set of perfect
matchings of a given graph so here the
graph is the succinctly presentation and
perfect matchings are not given
explicitly but you are given the graph
and here you want to design weight
assign deterministically because weight
assignments which will
my unique minimum weight perfect
matching in the graph more general
setting you can consider is a set of the
set of strings accepted by a circuit so
here every string you can view it is
effect so this the strings accepted by
circuit it you can see it as a family of
sets and you can talk about isolating
element in this family so I mean again
using the isolation lemma you know that
random weight assignment works so you
can use it to show that there exist list
of weight assignments so is that for any
succinct any family which section
representation one of the weight
assignment will work I mean it's the
standard argument and the goal here is
to construct such weight assignments
explicitly so this just shows existence
yeah so let's look at some examples
where this data mystic isolation is
known so first example is sparse
families if your family has only
polynomially many sets it's very easy to
isolate and here it is if if this part
simile is given to you explicitly
then it's really trivial that you can
just take one set you can assign zero
weight to all excel events and you can
ensure all other sets get a nonzero
weight so that's really simple but you
can do it even if you are if this part
family is not given to you so even in a
black box sense you can come up with a
list of weight assignments so that for
any sparse family one of these great
assignment will work so without this can
be done without knowing the given now
another example is spanning trees in a
graph so you just saw spanning trees you
just give different with different
weights to all the edges it's easy to
show that with such a weight assignment
the minimum weight spanning trees unique
integral in general is true for any
Metroid the maximum independent set so
if you give different weights then there
is
unique name of a maximal independent set
then there was a lot of work on perfect
matching for special graphs because the
effort was to read and memorize it for
for the perfect matching family for
general graph and I mean there are many
graphs classes like by project planar
graphs and Cordell strongly chordal
graphs and so on another example is this
HT paths in a graph and here we don't
know a polynomial polynomial bounded
weights we know quasi-polynomial
invented weights so we know an isolating
weight assignment with quasi
polynomially bounded weights so so and
it's easy to see actually so for just
for simplicity I will consider layered
graph so let's say we have some layered
graph from s to T they just are going
from this to T what you can do is you
split the graph I mean consider the
middle layer so and suppose recursively
assume that all paths from s to this
node there is a unique minimum weight
path from here to here same from here to
here from here to here same from here to
here here to T and so on so what you can
see now that from s to T there are
exactly n it max n minimum weight n
minimum weight path so you can give a
new weight assignment which
distinguishes among this n minimum
weight path and you need to do this in
log and rounds because this is a divide
and conquer approach so that that will
give you power C polynomial is bounded
ok another point I want to repeat it
again and if you could just find an SP
path you could assign zero weight here
and it went to all other edges so that
is a trivial way to isolate but we are
sort of assuming that we I mean we don't
have such so much power so so in fact in
the context of SP pass we want to
construct an isolating weight assignment
in log space because that this question
is related to the NL equal to energy
versus usual question
so so in general you can think of I mean
I would put the question this way that
in some sense you have to design your
isolating bit assignment in a black box
way you can't just go and find out the
set in your family yeah so I mean this
strings accepted by read well formula
returns branching programs this orders
wrong this is peapods and then recently
we have this two results on perfect
matchings in bipartite graphs and common
independent sets of two Metroid's and
here we can give isolating weight
assignments with quality polynomially
bounded which and this is the approach I
am going to present the roach also works
for this minimum vertex cover
minimum vertex cover sin of a patina I
mean this problem is related to perfect
matching cinemas particular so it this
is not very important our inside VMs the
NS I don't think anything
because it yeah I'll come to in the end
I will come to yes so now I will start
with the approach what is the approach
so so yeah the approach we will consider
this
pollito for the given family so for any
given set they for any given subset of
this set II you consider its
characteristic 0 1 vector so 1 if the
element is in the set 0 otherwise and
now for your family maybe you consider
this pollito PB which is nothing but the
convex hull of all these characteristic
vectors of your sex in your family so
this is a 0 1 for a 2 sitting in the I
to the E and its corners are exactly
coming from your sex in the family
because these are 0 and positive all
these sets will correspond to corners
they are not interior point so these
corners are exactly coming from your
searching your family and now what we do
is we the wait assignments on the
elements of your set II you it is a
function over this body 2 so what I mean
is you for any point in our to the e you
consider this function W dot X so if you
w as a vector vector in our to the E and
consider this dot portrait of robotics
and define this as the weight of this
point X so the point here is so this is
easy to observe that for any set s this
dot product of W with X s is nothing but
the weight of the set because X s is a
zero one vector then you take the dot
product it's just sum of the sum of the
weights of the element in the city so
easy observation is that this w weight
assignment is isolating for your family
d if and only if W dot X has a unique
minima over the polytope and the V dot X
is this linear function which will be
important so now our goal is we look at
this polytope PB which sits in our to
the e and we want to design a W
the W dot X has a unique minimum our
body to again we want small with
polynomially bounded which so the
strategy is that instead of doing it in
one go we will do it this in many rounds
so so first observe that for because W
dot X is a linear function for any such
W the points minimizing this W dot X in
the positive will form a series of the
positive so for example here it might be
this ways or or just an edge or a vertex
so our vertex is also fixed over Texas 0
dimension C's so so what we will do is
we'll start with some weight assignments
and that will give us some face let's
say this is the minimizing phase then
the strategies that modify your width
assignment slightly if you modify it too
much then maybe you will get a
completely different minimum minimizing
face so what we do is we slightly modify
it such that the now the new minimizing
face is the surface of your so maybe
this edge it's the surface of your
current face and so on so in each round
you try to decrease the dimension of
you're minimizing face and keep
decreasing the ya so you stop when you
reach the zero dimensional face which is
a vertex
yeah so so let me formalize this when I
say I'll slightly modify this weight
function what I mean is I can formalize
this so suppose you have the use of
weight assignment and W prime is another
weight assignment such that W prime is
bounded by this capital number n so
basically what we do is this W is our
current weight assignment and W 1 is our
new weight assignment which is obtained
by adding W prime with W but W is put on
a higher scale so W gets the old rate
function gets the higher preference so
the point is that I mean you can also
view it like this that your weight
function is basically W plus W prime by
n so this thing gets a look low priority
so basically your new minimizing phase
will be a subset of your old minimizing
field because this gives some minimizing
points and this further distinguishes
among them that's the only thing it does
yeah so note that this weight will grow
as exponentially in number of rounds
because of this multiplication by this
scaling so what we want ideally is
constantly mini rounds but what we can
achieve is this approach will give a log
in rooms so that will make it quasi
polynomially bounded which so yeah so
let me the important thing is how to in
each step how to reduce the phase
dimension significantly so we would like
something like constant fraction
reduction in the dimension of the page
so let us say s B so we have some great
function W 0 and let us say F 0 is the
minimizing phase consider any vector
parallel to the face so by vector
parallel to the face I mean
formerly it means that V is some alpha
times V 1 minus V 2 where V 1 and V 2
both are points in the face so something
like this so if this is the face you
take the point you consider this vector
so I call this vector parallel to the
face now any z observation is yes for
example if you take two vertices of the
face this vector is parallel to the page
so clearly this W 0 dot V is 0 because
because what we know is W 2 0 dot dot V
1 and W 0 dot V 2 because W 0 is the F 0
is the minimizing page so to be 0 these
two things are equal and W 0 dot V 1
minus V 2 is 0 so that we can say W 0
dot V T so now what we are going to do
is we will change our wave function so
is that the new weight function W 1 will
ensure that its dot product with V is
nonzero so that is how we would change
our weight function so this will imply
that now this chosen vector V is not
parallel to your new minimizing face
such a new minimizing festival so this
also tells you that F 1 is a strict
subset of F 0 because there is a vector
which is not parallel to reference but
it is it was perfect with you now again
the point is how to guarantee a
significant decrease in the dimension so
so what we are going to do instead of
just choosing one vector we'll choose
many Situationist parallel to the face
and will ensure that for all such
vectors this dot product is nonzero so
there are standard tricks to do this for
polynomially many vectors if I give you
polynomially many vectors which which
are polynomially bounded coefficients
then you can design you await
assignments such that for all VI is w
dot VI is non zero so there is a
standard trick for this you take
exponentially high weight which will be
which will clearly
mikachu can clearly achieve non-zero dot
product and then you but we want small
small all weights so what we do is we go
modular small numbers so if you try many
numbers what you can show is for one of
the J's W mode J will have this property
that W dot VI is nonzero for each eye
and the important thing is here is the
number the J's you need to try is
bounded by n K log P so basically if you
have polynomially many vectors you will
get polynomially bounded bit so we can
handle polynomially many vectors that is
the summary also important point is that
this construction is black box so we
don't need to know these vectors we just
need to know the bound on the
coefficients the bound on their number
and this scheme will work so this will
also be important that this such weight
assignment can be consulted in that so
now let's say we have some phase let's
say the set of integral vectors parallel
to the space arbitrary
in African economies the reason this
wouldn't work is because there could be
too many facets and we have two
different benefit which lowers the waste
by having to account for oh yeah so I in
the end I will come to a sufficient
condition and that I mean that will
clearly will not be true for all four
into so let's say LS is the set of
integral vectors parallel to the page
now what we do is in the first step
design of weight function W 0 which
gives non zero dot product to all all
rector's which lengths bounded lengths
let's say bounded by two or small
vectors
now once you do this you can do this
because there are only polynomial
mistress so you can do now let us say
the X 1 is the phase minimizing this
function W 0 so clearly X 1 now this in
this state elephant there are no lengths
to vector because we have ensured non
zero dot product with length odd for all
length two victors this length two
vectors cannot be parallel to a left one
so I mean integral is integral link to
it cannot be parallel to the physical
and so in some things we have removed
length two vectors from our face we keep
doing this in the next round we entered
length for victors so we again they are
polynomially bounded so we can ensure
non zero dot product so in the new phase
f2 now there are no lengths for with
three keep doing this each around double
the length of the vector few hundred and
in is around you
there are you can assume there are no
lengths due to the I Eustace and I want
nonzero dot product for length up to two
to the I plus one yes yes so what's the
I mean this this number can blow up how
many vectors of length two to the I plus
one there is no guarantee what we want
is it should be polynomially bounded
then this approach will work so and we
hope that this will be polymerized
bounded for some nice for it of assuming
that
the minimum length vectors are to to die
yes I'll come to precise condition what
will be so this suppose this this thing
remains polynomial bounding the number
of such vectors then there is no problem
and in log and rounds we will reach to a
phase where there are no lengths and
vectors and then the phase should be
accountable because because we are
dealing with zero 142 if there are two
corners in your current phase then you
can see this vector has length bounded
by M where m is the dimension and it is
parallel to the face so when we say
there are no lengths and vector it means
your face must be a corner so that gives
you a unique minimum that gives you a
unique minimum so I just come to this
sufficient condition which is
discounting this width so basically you
take faces and you consider this victors
parallel to your face so formally you
can say that if your face X equal to B
are the all the qualities satisfied by
your face then you consider all these
integral vectors which satisfy X equal
to 0 and what we want in this set LS is
this that suppose lambda 1 LS is the
length of the shortest vector in this
set what we want is the number of
vectors of length up to 2 lambda 1 M is
polynomially bounded so lambda 1 F is
the shortest so we come from shortest to
twice the shortest we want this to be
polynomially bounded and if we want this
for all faces Snitch
if this holds for all phases of your
poly tope then this achieves isolation
in this point
so now I want to show that this this
condition holds for the perfect matching
body so for bipartite graphs not for
general grams it only works so
perpetrator
so for bipartite graph the perfect
matching polytope is given by these two
set of constraints the first is just non
negativity X figure to 0 second
constraint is saying that for all edges
incident on a vertex the sum should be 1
so I mean you can see that for every
perfect matching you take exactly one
edge incident on a vertex so this is
just saying that the around every vertex
the sum should be 1 exactly 1 yeah so it
turns out that these two constraints
define the polytope of perfect matchings
now what is the face so the only
inequalities are this non negativity
constraint so when you look at a face
it's just you for you choose some edges
some subset of edges put X equal to 0
that's how a face can look like and what
is this LF the integral vectors parallel
to your page they are nothing but for
this side edge they will satisfy X equal
to 0 and for each vertex you need this
sum around the vertex should be 0
because we shift the face to origin and
then look at the integral yeah now what
are these vectors
so what are the vectors which satisfy
these two constraints so you can forget
about this X equal to zero this means
just you delete these edges now look at
the rest of the edges the rest of the
edges you need this condition that on
each vertex the sum should be zero so
consider any cycle in your graph now
consider this vector plus 1 minus 1 plus
1 minus 1 so such a vector has the
property that some around every vertex
is 0 the sum around this vertex is 0
somewhere on this vertex is 0 and so
this this kind of litter will satisfy
these two constraints in fact you can
show that all all the integral vectors
satisfying these two constraints are
actually integral combination of such
cycles so basically the question when we
are in a phase basically we are in a sub
graph and when we say our shortest
vector is lambda 1 then shortage vector
length is lambda 1 it means the shortage
cycle in your graph is length some bound
let's say lambda 1 and now you want to
bound the number of cycles up to length
twice that length so the this lemma
shows exactly that that for any graph if
you assume there are no cycles of length
of 2 R then the number of cycles up to
lengths to R is polynomially bounded and
that's the only thing we needed in the
because the cycles are exactly the
integral vectors parallel to the P yes
so this again has a simple proof and
then I will be done
so how do you show this bound on cycles
so you know there are no cycles of
length R consider any cycle of light to
R so let's this is a cycle of length 2
are divided into four equal parts and
let's say these nodes are u 1 u 2 u 3 u
4 now with this cycle see we associate
this stuff well u 1 u 2 u 3 u 4 now the
claim is if you take an another cycle C
Prime
this couple will be different suppose
this is 2 this plane is 2 now the number
of tuples can be at most n to the 4 so
that will give a bound on the number of
so why there should be different tuples
so assume there is you get same temple
for both the cycles so the cycle C prime
may be passes like this and goes like
this and this and so on now because this
was divided into equal parts the all
parts were less than R by 2 all points
of Lisbon are met but now here you see
there are 2 parts both of length less
than R by 2 this will give you a cycle
of length R which is a contradiction
because we assume there are no cycles of
liquor so this gives the bound on the
number of cycles of two lengths to are
assuming the running cycle simple so
this proves the disk efficient
conditions that if lambda 1 be the
length of the shortest vector then we
want to bond number of length the test
link to lambda
yeah so another example example where
this works is this metroid intersection
problem so now I don't have time to much
to go into the details but what it turns
out is this it's positive is well-known
but it's fueled by advanced you look at
the polytope you analyze how its phase
can look like it turns out its phase
will have exactly these sort of
constraints which comes from the
bipartite graph so actually you will get
a bipartite graph and the integral
solutions parallel to the face will
exactly come from cycles of some
bipartite graph you can build a
bipartite graph and the cycles of that
graph will give you the victors and
again we are already shown the bound on
number of short cycles so that solves
this linear Metroid intersection problem
yeah yes the quotient open question is
for what other positives we can show
this kind of bound assumed I mean number
of short victims purse short integral
with this can we show it
polynomially bounded yeah so when open
when question is matching in general
graphs for which we don't know yeah
another question was this
in the beginning there was this
reduction from sad to and my Cossacks
so there we need to do a randomized we
need to isolate among that satisfying
assignments of a given formula so this
approach cannot work in such a setting
because we don't know a positive for the
satisfying assignments or performance
because I mean and there is no hope to
know that unless in P equal to go in P
you cannot have a nice description of
this poly tube
so this approach certainly will not work
in that city a good question was the
next speaker setup is this an example
for something on which approximate
counting is easy first it is number -
little mistake isolation is going to be
hard known to be hard and I did not know
about them in plausibly give the
following statement plausible that
whenever you have a proper accounting
your vertex position so it is perfect
lighting in Finland enough so they you
can count exactly perfect matching since
later but isolation is not known till
now but I am NOT saying it can't be no
man taking if I take metal obviously
something immediately
let's take other questions off light
[Applause]
the next one PRV for small stages in
Korea analysis by Thomas